The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Social movements remind
you of the picture
we had the first day,
and once or twice--
I should have done
it more often since--
but on the first day we've been
talking about policy making.
We did on Monday.
We talked mainly
about interest groups
here, a little bit about
regulatory processes.
We'll come back to
that on Wednesday.
But up here at the top is
this vague outside the box--
outside these boxes, at least,
category of norms and customs
and values and traditions
and institutions
that we had movements in
their, social movements.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
We're going to talk about
what they are, how they differ
from other policy
actors, how they work,
and briefly, what impacts can we
see on energy and environmental
policy.
So if you think about
who effects policy,
there are obviously individual
firms or households.
And in the US setting
you have to think about
for federal policy.
You have to think about some
federal governments that
occasionally tribes.
What we talked
about last time were
all of these, this alphabet
soup of interest groups
that you will find on
K Street in Washington,
and you'll find various
analogs in state capitals.
Sometimes they fly in.
For those who don't live
in this world, that's
the National Rifle Association,
the American Forrest Products
Association, the Environmental
Defense Fund, the AFL/CIO,
the Union Organization,
the American Association
of Retired People, which sends
you mailings when you turn 50
to show you're really old.
The American Petroleum
Institute, the National Coal
Institute, and
there are many more.
Then there are
political parties.
Republican, Democrat,
or Democratic,
depending on which parity
you affiliate with.
Green parties in lots of places,
Whig parties in US history,
plenty of other parties
in various places.
And then social movements.
So the best way I find to
think about a social movement
is to think about examples.
So as I go back to my
period of consciousness,
there are a number of them
that come to mind, and let
me just walk through a few.
There is the Civil
Rights Movement.
That's the group gathering to
hear Dr. Martin Luther King.
Not all those people were
paying dues to anything
or had membership
cards to anything,
but they had all
come to Washington.
Most people would probably
call the Civil Rights
Movement successful, maybe not.
This is the Anti-Vietnam
War Movement.
That, of course, is at MIT.
This was in 1970.
The picture-- and that's
some other campus,
and this is Washington.
The picture I looked for
very hard but couldn't find,
and I know it
exists, is a picture
of the then President
of MIT, Howard Johnson,
marching with a
group of students
down Mass Avenue with
an anti-war banner.
That movement, you might
call successful ultimately.
But I'm going to
come back to this.
You might ask, why?
Most of those people were
too young to vote, so why was
that movement successful?
Or did the movement
have anything to do
with ending the war, actually?
This is the
environmental movement.
That's an early rally.
Senator Muskie in Washington--
I think that's in Washington,
addressing a group.
And the tree hugger on the
right, I couldn't resist.
So there you've got the
environmental movement.
Successful?
Maybe, maybe not.
Also, you'll notice one
of the interest groups
I had up there was the
Environmental Defense Fund.
So one might want to think
about where that boundary is,
and we'll come back to that.
The Women's Movement.
You see there, the--
I think that's the entirety
of the Equal Rights
Amendment, for which
there was also opposition.
As regards the Equal
Rights Amendment,
you could argue that
was pretty successful.
Those-- you don't see
votes like that anymore.
The Equal Rights Amendment
phrased on the left
passed the House in 1972 354
to 24, in the Senate, 84 to 8.
That means there were a lot
of Republican votes for it.
30 states ratified it by the
end of 1973, but it failed.
They needed 38 to pass.
It got 35 by 1979.
Never got to 30--
all of these pieces of--
all of these amendments have
a deadline for ratification.
The deadline here was
'79, and it didn't make it
and some states
rescinded ratification.
And I don't think
you could get that--
I don't think you could get that
Amendment voted on in Congress
now, let alone passed.
So you've got to ask, was
that movement successful?
That was a movement.
I mean, you got
troops turning out.
You got rallies.
You got an anti movement.
Was that movement successful?
What did it do?
This is a more recent one.
You may recall the meetings of
the World Trade Organization,
the International Organization
that basically sets trading
rules for international trade.
For a period, those
meetings were dangerous.
I don't know whether this
is the one in Seattle,
but Downtown Seattle
got sort of trashed
by people who were
protesting globalization,
protesting the WTO, which is
a bunch of bureaucrats who
deal with trade disputes
and associated it
with global injustice.
1999.
That movement failed.
I think that's
fair to say, right?
We have globalized.
Trade has not turned
back, and that movement
has pretty much vanished.
How come?
How come some succeed
and some fail?
This is the
anti-nuclear movement.
This is international.
This is-- that's Germany,
[SPEAKING GERMAN]..
That's Japan, and
that, of course,
is Vermont, where the future
of the Vermont Yankee Nuclear
Plant is much debated.
Is that movement successful?
That movement start--
well, I'm going
to come back to that movement,
because we'll talk about that,
actually, at some length.
But that movement is global.
A lot of power plants
have been built
since that movement started,
a lot of nuclear plants still
active.
This is the anti-fracking
movement, more recently.
That's New York, as you see.
That's somewhere in Paris, and
that, I believe, is Bulgaria.
So it, like the
anti-nuclear movement,
is fairly broad geographically.
Has succeeded in some places,
succeeded at least tentatively
in New York and in France.
I have no idea what the
status is in Bulgaria.
The Tea Party movement,
look at those numbers.
Has the Tea Party movement
succeeded? will the Tea Party
movement last?
How does the Tea
Party movement work?
And, of course, on
the other side--
by the way, that's impressive.
That's Washington.
That's Pennsylvania
Avenue full of people.
This is the opposite side of
the coin, the Occupy Movement.
Again, jobs not cuts whereas
the-- we want less over here.
And jobs not cuts over here.
So you have two opposed
social movements as we speak.
And then most
dramatically, this is
a good time for this topic, most
dramatically, the Arab Spring.
So as you go around, there's
Tahrir Square in Egypt.
There's Tunisia.
There's Yemen.
Government toppled, government
toppled, government toppled.
Bahrain, protests continuing.
Syria, Civil War.
Libya, government toppled.
Social movements.
OK, there are a lot of them.
This is just one
slice of history,
a recent slice of history.
I'm going to come back and
talk about some of them.
But the first thing we
ought to worry about
is, what are these things?
How are they distinct
from other actors?
Certainly, they're trying
to influence policy.
That's what they're there for.
Not always in a
coherent way, not always
in a well-defined way.
The anti-globalization movement,
what exactly did they want?
What's the Occupy Movement want?
But in any case, they're
trying to-- not necessarily
with a specific
agenda, but they're
trying to have some influence.
This is easy.
I listed these
actors at the start.
They're not a formal
part of the process.
They're not on the ballot.
They're not registered.
They don't have national
committees and slates
of candidates formally.
The boundary between a social
movement and an interest group,
though, and Burstein
talks about, this
is a little blurrier, right?
[? Lowey, ?] whom
we read earlier,
has this italicized phrase,
which is interesting.
All established interest
groups are conservative.
And he means conservative
not in the sense
of left, right, in the sense
of less government, more
government, but in the
old-fashioned sense
of less change, more change.
So he means they are
conservative in the sense
that interest groups tend
to resist radical change.
They're part of the system.
The American Forrest
Products Association
has some laws it likes, has
some laws it doesn't like,
lobbies here, lobbies there.
If you said, let's fundamentally
rethink the way we do timber,
they'd be appalled
because that's not
what they're there for.
OK.
So that's-- and they also tend
to be more structured, right?
The Environmental Defense Fund
has members, has a budget,
has offices, has
lobbyists, writes papers.
They do routine influence.
They lobby.
They enter briefs in court.
They send in petitions.
Social movements tend
to be on the margins,
tend to be on the
margins of the system.
Membership is not well defined.
Who was a member of the
Civil Rights Movement?
Who was a member of
the anti-war movement,
anti-Vietnam movement?
Almost everybody I
knew did something.
None of us had cards.
And they tend to engage in what
you'd call non-routine actions,
like marches and demonstrations
and chaining themselves
to fences and all of that stuff.
They vary, resources,
organization, tactics.
Greenpeace is an
interesting example, right?
Greenpeace is noted for its
anti-whaling activities,
has ships, intercepts,
interferes with whaling.
That's a non-routine action.
It also has lobbyists
in various capitals
to push for various things.
So Greenpeace is
an interest group
in the sense of being
organized and having
members and dues and
stuff, but it also
engages in non-standard tactics.
But all of the examples
social movements I had
tend to be without a
defined membership.
Who was part of the Arab Spring?
Varied from day to day.
Who showed up for
the demonstrations?
Who's part of the anti-Putin
movement, to the extent
it is a movement, in Russia?
Who comes?
Who was part of the
anti-war movement?
Civil Rights Movement?
So the membership
tends to be unclear.
The actions tend
to be non-standard.
The anti-Vietnam
movement did engage
in massive letter
writing campaigns,
which is pretty standard.
But it also occupied the
MIT president's office
and various other University
presidents offices,
which is pretty non-standard.
So it's a mixture.
Thoughts about this so far?
OK.
So how do they work
when they work?
How might any of these
affect public policy?
What are the mechanisms?
Why do they matter?
What do they ever matter?
What are they doing?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes,
it's trying to show
that if a politician
does something
that these social
movements-- or back
something these social
movements find distasteful,
unpopular, [INAUDIBLE]
less likely to get elected.
[INAUDIBLE] an example might
be that [INAUDIBLE] People
made it very clear that
this was not something
they supported, and so
politicians backed away
from it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So one
mechanism is in a sense,
they provide information or
they demonstrate salience.
Salience is awareness.
So an issue's salient
to me if I'm aware of it
and I consider it important.
So you could argue that the
anti-Vietnam protests made
it clear that, to at least
a segment of the population,
all of us who could get
drafted, we were very
aware of what was going on.
It was very important to us.
We felt strongly.
OK, so they can provide
information about salience,
about the population's feelings.
How else might it work?
Yeah, Brendan?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You could just--
not necessarily
motivate the politician.
You also motivate other
people to come on board.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you might--
well, there are two ways
you might do that, right?
One way is to
change preferences.
You could persuade people that--
by getting them to think about
it, that this group is right.
You could argue that was a
large part of what Martin Luther
King did, and the effective
leadership of the Civil Rights
Movement.
It persuaded a lot of people
that the current state
of affairs was just
wrong, full stop, wrong.
It blurs with raise salience.
I think these two
are hard to separate,
because it could be that
an awful lot of people
in the North were
unaware of just how
segregated the South was.
So you made people aware of
it by increasing awareness.
That works, of course,
if they agree with you.
Charlotte?
AUDIENCE: I also think
that, going along
with the trend of getting
more people involved,
just having a group makes people
who already have that belief,
maybe are already aware of
the issue, but just unaware
of how they could affect
it, join together.
And then it [INAUDIBLE] just
because there are more bodies.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So this is--
AUDIENCE: Like attract
people, I guess [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The-- yeah.
Yeah.
The model Burstein
has is that works
if it makes a politician
rethink, rethink
their prospects.
And so I guess I'd sort of
put that one in a way here.
But you'd say it not only
demonstrates to politicians
that a lot of people
care about, it
demonstrates to a
lot of other people
that people care about it.
And that's a lot of the story
of the Arab Spring, I think,
is you've got a few
people who are just
sufficiently outraged that they
would risk getting shot at.
And other people said,
well, I feel that way, too,
and if they're going to do
that, maybe I should do that.
And at some point you
demonstrate to the regime
that it lacks popular support.
And regimes that
aren't Democratic
tend to not have much idea
how much support they have,
and it's easy to exaggerate
how much support you have.
Because every time
you go out in public
and have a parade, people cheer.
Because they-- why
wouldn't you cheer?
The dictator's going by.
So that's interesting.
You can say it sort
of rallies people,
and I think those are the most
plausible ways we've got them.
The others-- Burstein
looks at people
who argue that these
somehow persuade, as
in a logical sense.
But that's not
plausible, he says,
and I agree with
him, that they're not
going to-- you don't
march in the streets
to make an
intellectual argument.
You march in the streets
to do something else.
And if it isn't going to
affect re-election, why bother?
And if it is, why is
the group necessary
if the person knows it?
You could argue that the
anti-Vietnam demonstrations
simply made it inescapable that
there was widespread opposition
to the war.
Public opinion polls
said the same thing,
but marching in the streets made
us all feel better, of course.
But also, brought it home.
The other point I'm making
here in that second bullet
is donors.
I mean, gun control is
an interesting example
of the impact of salience
and the impact of an interest
group.
Polls say that 70% of
Americans-- typically,
the number varies a little
bit, but 70% of Americans
would favor some gun
control, say limits
on assault weapons on campus.
You-- or some restrictions
on carrying weapons.
But most people don't care much.
Every police chief
favors gun control.
Most people don't care much.
People who support
the National Rifle
Association, who oppose
gun control, care a lot,
and they win.
Because the fact that
I favor gun control
is not going to cause
me, in most cases,
to change my vote on anything,
because that's rarely
a big campaign issue.
If I'm elected, I will enact--
no.
That's rarely a campaign issue.
So those of us who care a
little bit don't do anything,
and those who care a lot and
have some money have control.
So that's a concentrated
interest diffuse interest
example of some importance.
So the other ways we talked
about providing information.
You could argue that's
what happened in Vietnam.
That's what happened
in East Germany.
When-- I didn't put up
the demonstrations that
brought down the Berlin Wall,
but as distinct from the Arab
Spring, nobody got shot, right?
That happened quickly.
They talked about
the Velvet Revolution
in Czechoslovakia, talked
about in East Germany,
nothing much happened.
Crowds turned out,
crowds turned out.
They didn't seize the
government buildings.
They didn't overrun the
president's or prime minister's
house.
The government just
gave up and left.
So I think the argument
here is that they provided
enormous amount of
information to voters
that you have no support.
You're loathed.
Changing preferences.
This often has to do
with reframing an issue.
Think about the
pro-life movement,
which is a brilliant
piece of reframing.
How can you be against life?
I mean, you're for choice,
but what's more important,
choice or life?
So you could argue that
reframing the issue as,
are you for or against life,
has an impact on preferences.
The attacks on the
health care legislation
by making it Obama's legislation
as opposed to, by the way,
no pre-existing condition,
universal insurance, blah,
blah, blah, changes
how it's thought of.
It's something Obama is
shoving down our throats.
And you can argue that
Civil Rights did that,
that that was the essence of
the Civil Rights Movement.
That if you saw in real time
the marchers being taken down
with fire hoses, it was hard
not to think, that's just wrong.
These people are marching.
How can they--
why is that right?
So and you don't do--
King's speeches were important,
but watching people peacefully
protest being beaten changes
your views of the people
beating them and of the issue.
So part of what they
do social movements
is theater that changes
preferences as well
as signals information.
You can raise salience by
making people aware of an issue,
but it only works if they
agree with you, right?
I mean, think about
globalization,
the anti-globalization movement.
So they protested globalization.
They protested poor working
conditions in poor countries,
and they trashed Starbucks.
And most people said what?
I'm sorry.
If you're very sympathetic to
poor people, you say, yeah.
They should pay people
more in poor countries.
And if you're not,
you say, well, they
don't have to take
the jobs, you know?
I mean, they're not being forced
to work in these factories.
It's more fun than
being in a village.
So the example-- one of the
optional readings, C and G--
I forget now what
their initials are--
make the point that
among people who
are for environmental
change and who
were opposed to environmental
change in a survey,
awareness of environmental
issues was equal.
Values differed.
So the policy
implications differed.
So you make people
aware that there's
a lot of international trade,
and a lot of what you buy
is produced by people
in poor countries,
one response is,
that's really terrible.
Another response is,
well, that's a market.
And if people
mainly think, that's
a market because
that's what they value,
making them more aware
of an issue won't help.
You could argue the same thing
happens with climate change.
There's been a lot of work--
I wouldn't call it a movement,
but an awful lot of people
have spent a lot of time
trying to educate people
about climate change.
It has not produced
a groundswell.
Quite the contrary.
And the argument is that
it comes up against it's
a conflict of values.
Do you want to have
economic growth,
or do you want to have
environmental protection?
We can both be aware of
climate change and its issues,
but reach very different
policy conclusions.
So raising salience only
works, raising awareness
only works if there's agreement
or potential agreement,
or something like agreement.
And the final way, and
this is the borderline--
this isn't really
social movement.
I think the Burstein article
is, nonetheless, a good article.
For interest groups, how do
interest groups affect policy?
Well, they do all this
other stuff, right?
The National Rifle Association
does advertise, does--
the Environmental Defense
Fund does send out mailings
to people, so these
people do engage
in the organized petition
drives that do all this.
But interest groups
work on implementation.
That's inside baseball, right?
So we'll talk about it
in the environmental case
next time when we
talk about what
EPA did to set standards
a couple of times.
But the Dodd-Frank law is the
big current example, right?
You can read about it in
the paper all the time.
The law required lots
of regulations, set up
some new entities, and it
required this regulation,
that regulation.
Spell this out, make
this clear, hundreds,
thousands of
regulations required.
No votes in Congress.
Really, really boring stuff.
Who wins?
The people who have
offices in Washington,
who have lawyers, who have
staff, who have resources.
It's not a matter of buying
votes in regulatory agencies.
It's a matter of
providing information,
lobbying, per the piece we
had assigned for last time.
When the issue has low
salience to the public--
interchange fees
on debit cards I
will tell you exercise the
entire banking industry,
and it may have
been in the Globe
twice on the third
business page.
Every banker in the
country was up in arms.
The Federal Reserve was
required to regulate that.
It had enormous discretion.
It was required to regulate
that fee paying due attention
to incremental costs.
Incremental costs
varied all over the lot.
Hundreds of submissions went
into the Federal Reserve.
They made a decision.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So that's the
Durbin Amendment, right?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The
Durbin Amendment, yep.
AUDIENCE: So when that--
so when that was approved,
the fact that, for instance,
Bank of America started
charging monthly fee
for people when
they use their debit
card to try to offset the
fact that they couldn't make
as much money from
marginal cost--
like the marginal revenue
that they had before.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't that
cause people to care a lot?
Because at the end of the
day, the regular customer
was the one who kind of got
screwed over a little bit,
and the merchants
were the ones who won.
But wouldn't
eventually like people
be against the Dodd-Frank?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, you
mean against that Amendment.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, I mean here's--
here are the-- this was a
fight in which I participated.
Here's what happens
in the short run.
What happens in the short run
is merchants save a little bit
on debit card transactions.
Not enough to cause
them to cut prices,
because it's only a little bit.
So one person, one large chain
said on a conference call--
I think it was Home Depot--
said on a conference
call that that
was worth about $100 million
to them, short run profits.
So prices don't go down.
What happens to
banks is checking
accounts are now
less profitable,
so they look to
recoup in other ways.
They tried the monthly fee.
That didn't work.
The easiest thing to do, and
what they've done quietly,
is they've raised the
minimum balances required
for free checking.
And we'll see the
numbers, but checking,
because of these fees, if
you use the debit card a lot,
the bank is--
you're profitable to the
bank even if you don't leave
a lot of money on deposit.
Take away those fees,
you're no longer profitable.
So they start raising
the minimum requirement
for free checking,
and the number
of people without
checking accounts goes up.
So, I mean, that's the
predictable consequence
of the amendment.
It was pushed by merchants,
and Senator Durbin
talked about his friend, I think
it was a hardware store owner
or drug store owner, who was
being taken to the cleaners
by these fees.
So he's presumably happy.
In the long run, costs
get passed through.
It's just they're frictions
to changing prices,
so in the short run they don't.
In the long run,
prices adjust up.
People pay slightly
more if they use cash.
So-- but this is a typical--
this is a-- this is an
extreme piece of legislation.
It was not debated, really.
It got a floor vote--
a quick floor vote, not much
material on it anywhere.
It said to the Federal
Reserve, neglect
the fixed costs of running these
programs when you set a price.
Wait, what?
They have to cover
the fixed cost.
OK, neglect the fixed costs,
and it instructed the Fed
to consider marginal cost.
The Fed ran a survey.
Marginal costs varied by
roughly an order of magnitude
across banks.
OK, now what do you do?
And they came out
with a proposed rule.
There was the expected howling.
They doubled the ceiling.
There was less howling.
Life goes on.
But yeah, it'll have
the effect of increasing
the number of unbanked people.
It's not as serious
as it used to be
not to have a bank account,
but it's still pretty serious.
So yeah.
The Durbin Amendment,
you follow this stuff.
That's amazing.
It's not even energy.
Anything else while I pause
for breath and anecdote?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you tell us
a little bit about the role
that social media has
paid like how to mobilize
all these different publics?
Like, I can see with Occupy Wall
Street and Occupy Everything
how [INAUDIBLE] come together.
I saw that.
But something like the
Civil Rights Movement--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But it's
a little less clear, isn't it,
how--
the Occupy Movement,
I find mysterious.
Because the Civil
Rights Movement
had a set of
charismatic leaders.
It had some clear objectives,
and it had great media
coverage, right?
I mean, when those
kids went to-- where
was it that the Civil
rights workers got shot?
Selma, maybe?
Boy, that coverage of
three college students
go down to help the
black community organize
in Selma, Alabama and get shot
for their troubles, that woke
people up in an amazing way.
And when you watch them
fire hose the marchers,
that was galvanizing.
And when Dr. Martin Luther
King spoke, that was, oh, gee.
There is something here.
Occupy was mysterious.
Occupy just happened.
I don't know.
These things-- and the
anti-globalization, similarly.
What was-- I can point
to triggering events.
You go back to the
Rosa Parks refusing
to sit in the back of the bus,
people moving into integrated
lunch counters, all of this
getting media attention.
I can see-- the triggering
events in Civil Rights
were clear.
The triggering event in
Vietnam was pretty clear.
It just went on and on, and
thinking about thousands
of people chanting,
hey, hey, LBJ.
How many kids did
you kill today?
Those are pretty
dramatic things.
But Occupy, I don't know
what triggered Occupy.
I also don't know what
triggered the anti-globalization
movement.
We know the Arab Spring.
We know it was the--
normally, there's something.
The guy in Tunisia who burned
himself to death in protest.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but like how people
are mobilizing come together.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, now you--
now people point
to, particularly
in the case of Egypt, it was
much discussed social media.
You can organize through
Twitter and Facebook
and various other
connections, and just things
going viral in a variety
of ways through people's
personal networks.
You can organize.
Vietnam was posters.
There will be a rally today,
AUDIENCE: There was a
leader that called it all.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
There were people who
appointed themselves leaders.
You put up a poster
and you say there's
going to be a demonstration
today in [INAUDIBLE] well,
it was then the great court,
nobody had to show up.
If people weren't
ready to do something,
you can imagine calling
a rally and nobody comes.
That happens often enough.
This, as far as I know,
and undoubtedly there's--
people have written
boring papers on it,
but it strikes me just
as an observer of history
that it's a bit
mysterious what does it.
It's a bit mysterious.
So guy burns himself
to death in Tunisia.
Why does that spread?
What triggers that?
Did somebody in Egypt set
himself up or herself up
as a leader and began
saying, hey, we're
going to meet in
the square tomorrow,
and then gradually it
built. It did build
from a relatively small group.
But in Moscow, there are
protests that have lost,
have plainly lost.
Their anti-Putin protests
in Russia, they were small.
I don't know how they happened.
They weren't sufficient.
They dissipated.
So it doesn't always happen.
Doesn't always happen.
Andrew?
AUDIENCE: Just as-- it
might be an extreme,
could someone argue
that, especially
in, say, for the Arab Spring
movements, that violence
or the threat of
violence, or blackmail
or the threat of just
physically destroying something
is a means of affecting
public policy?
So not votes, just
the fact that there's
a big body out there that will
affect the way the country
is run.
So let's read their demands.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, a standard thing
that happens, although in France
it tends to be well organized,
mass strikes.
You can call it-- you
call a general strike.
And if the general
strike is effective,
you've demonstrated
that you have the--
that enough--
you've demonstrated
there are enough people
care enough about the issue
to do something.
I don't know if it has
to be physical violence,
but I think it has
to be an action.
Because that's how you
demonstrate that you care,
right?
I mean, now, of course, you
just send an email to Congress.
No, that doesn't
really say that you're
very excited about the issue.
If you go out and
march, you stand
in the hot sun for a few
hours, it demonstrates it.
The story of the
Civil Rights Movement
is kind of the reverse, right?
There was no threat of
violence from the activists.
It was the violence from
those acting against them
that really built support.
It was Dr. King's
nonviolent strategy
which worked beyond
anything I've seen.
In the anti-Vietnam, people
were pretty nonviolent, too.
I don't think it mattered much.
Occupy has been nonviolent.
The Tea Party, been a little
shrill but nonviolent.
Tea Party's had some effect
politically in the Republican
Party.
The Occupy Movement seems to
have vanished in the night.
So it's a little bit mysterious.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] because
you mentioned strikes.
Because one another where
would that category [INAUDIBLE]
So say some people
said, I don't know,
like tomorrow all
bus drivers decided
that they want to strike.
So for some reason actually
that's more pertinent in Europe
where transportation is, but
I guess I've seen it happen.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Those are those
tend to be very heavily union.
That's why I talked
about a general strike.
AUDIENCE: So I was going
to say, even for a union.
So because it's a
relatively small body,
but because it exhibits a big--
a lot of power and
the fact that we
will have buses or
the subway tomorrow,
will bother a bigger
majority of people.
And basically, that's
almost like blackmail.
So you're influencing what
the majority of people
is thinking about this issue.
It's not that it's
directly influencing
what you're asking for, which
could be wages for bus drivers.
But they're so frustrated that
we don't have buses, so OK,
let's give them the
wages because they're
causing all this--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
But it can fail.
It could fail.
There was a-- I was
reading recently
a fictionalized treatment of the
famous police strike in Boston
in 1919.
That strike, police
hadn't been paid.
They were underpaid, hadn't
gotten a raise in 30 years
kind of thing, badly underpaid.
They struck.
There was a crime wave.
The police completely
lost the popular sympathy,
and lots of them were fired and
jailed and all kinds of things.
So that was the threat.
They carried out the threat.
People got very, very angry,
made Calvin Coolidge president
because of how drastically he
reacted against the strike.
So it's not necessarily
a winning strategy.
It's not necessarily
Another hand?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm confused by the
difference between the first
and the second strategies.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
The first-- yeah.
I must say reading
that reading the paper,
I was a little confused
about his argument, too.
He said, well, can you
just walk in and say,
I'm opposed to the Vietnam War.
I've got-- there are bunch of
us and here are my arguments.
And I think what he's saying
is, that's not going to work.
Social movements
work by demonstrating
that it matters
to enough people,
that you have to
take it into account.
And if the policymaker
knows that it
matters enough to
a lot of people,
you don't need a
social movement.
And if it doesn't--
Occupy-- if it doesn't, the
movement won't have any effect.
I think that's what he's saying.
In my money, in
social movements,
what you want to think about
is to think about these three.
Are you persuading people
that a lot of people care?
Are you making-- changing
people's preferences
toward an issue?
Are you making them
more aware of an issue
and making it more important?
You could be aware of fracking.
You could make it more important
in people's-- in people's minds
by providing information.
You could raise salience
either by awareness
or on the important side.
And this is an inside
baseball story.
So I share your confusion
about the first.
I confess, I read his
argument on the first one
and I said, well, what
would that look like?
The closest thing I can
think of is maybe in Vietnam
there was some
persuasion, but I think
what Vietnam was
all about was this,
was letting people know that
a large part of the population
was passionate.
And that's what happened
in Czechoslovakia,
in East Germany, and generally
throughout Eastern Europe.
Once it became
clear the Russians
weren't going to
intervene militarily,
and it became clear
to the government
that they had no popular
support, game over.
Game over.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm not
sure if I'm correct,
but my theory, my [INAUDIBLE]
theory for the Occupy Movement,
is that it wasn't
necessarily [INAUDIBLE]
by any particular event.
However, there was-- since
the financial crisis and then
all the economic problems that
were happening in the country.
I think there were just a
lot of people unsatisfied
with the current status.
But I don't think that would
have been enough to trigger
that movement in--
for this particular case.
I think the actual people,
the initial leaders
who tried to convince
people, those
are really the key players.
I don't think that's
something that would have--
that was bound to happen,
regardless of whether or not
someone had started.
I don't think it would
have been something
that if it didn't
happen then, it would
have happened two months after.
I just think that the people
who initially organized it
did a really good job.
They [INAUDIBLE] this
anarchy concept of--
they had all those masks of
that movie V for Vendetta.
And they [INAUDIBLE]
that image, and they
were just very secretive about
how they attracted people.
They became viral
and [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Became viral,
but what's interesting
is you point
to the particular leaders.
I mean, they occupied Portland,
Oregon for heaven's sakes.
What was that about?
This was a protest
against global capitalism?
Have you been to
Portland, Oregon?
I mean, this is not
the financial hub
of the Western
world with millions
of people getting rich on the
backs of the masses, right?
It's a pretty mellow place.
But they occupied Portland.
So they occupied
a lot of places.
I give up.
Let me move on.
Yeah, Julian?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I was
going to try, but undoubtedly
as profound.
Give it a shot.
AUDIENCE: I think, [INAUDIBLE]
it's kind of the precipitation
of a general sentiment that the
government isn't necessarily
benefiting [INAUDIBLE]
I feel like [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Which
is exactly what the Tea Party
people thought, too,
which is interesting.
I mean that's it.
There's something wrong
in Washington, something
wrong with a
different diagnosis.
AUDIENCE: Different diagnosis.
I mean, very different ideas
in the Tea Party movement.
But it's just a general
precipitation of some things
wrong you don't necessarily like
it from a financial statement.
The grand majority of
people that took place in--
they don't necessarily
know what is wrong
or exactly how to
fix it to begin with.
So I think that's one of
the reasons why it died out
is that it just became a
general shout of, I'm angry.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] nothing--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And you
saw a lot of movements of the,
I'm angry variety during
the Great Depression,
from both left and right.
So it does-- you do
get this in hard times.
There was a--
I think sometime in the
'30s, there was a World War I
veterans March on
Washington because pensions
weren't adequate.
And you got the rise of both
extreme left and extreme
right political
groups on the grounds
that it's just not right.
The Tea Party movement has
more heft because it actually
has clearer objectives, right?
There's a caucus in Congress.
There are relatively
organized groups
in some congressional districts.
Tea Party backing is a big deal.
They have a convention,
so they've made themselves
into an interest group from a
movement, interestingly enough.
With a little incoherence.
There was a split
between the Boston Tea
Party and the Worcester
Tea Party recently,
so they had separate rallies.
The Worcester Tea
Party said, we're
all about low taxes and limited
government and stuff like that.
And the Boston Tea
Party said, yeah,
and we hate gay marriage, too.
And the Worcester people
said, no, maybe we
ought to just stay focused.
So they split.
Anyway.
OK.
To get a little
closer to this course
and a little less abstract,
there's an interesting--
the other assigned
paper is [INAUDIBLE]
which is about nuclear power.
And they trace the partial
evolution of the politics here.
What did the politics
of nuclear power
look like in the '50s and '60s?
Movements, interest
groups, what?
That was a hand?
No, it was not waving.
OK.
Yeah.
Brandon, you got it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I think it was
kind of like, let's do this.
This is gonna be-- it's gonna
cost pennies to-- it's going
to cost you penny--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Too
cheap to meter was the phrase.
Too cheap to meter.
AUDIENCE: It was
very enthusiastic.
The navy was going nuclear.
There was a lot of
proliferation technology
out there so these reactors
were ready to build.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And the politics
was industry interest
groups, right?
There were-- the paper
labeled a bunch of them.
The big thing, their
big win was there's
a limit still in force
on the liability of any--
related to any nuclear facility.
The Atomic Energy
Commission was regulatory,
but it also was promoting Atomic
Energy as well as regulating.
So it was like the early
years of airline travel
where what politics
there was was positive,
industry groups dominated,
inside the beltway stuff.
Not much in the media, except
for cheap, swell, good, clean,
et cetera.
What happened in the '70s?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It was a
combination of a movie called
The China Syndrome that came
out and then Three Mile Island--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
China Syndrome
might have been a little
later, but go ahead.
Not much later.
AUDIENCE: They were similar.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It followed
Three Mile Island a little bit.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Three Mile Island happened,
which seemed to mimic the
movie with like, oh geez,
this is reality.
It's actually dangerous.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And you began
to get a different kind
of politics, right?
Politically, what did you get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I showed you.
What was on that slide?
You've got an
anti-nuclear movement.
You've got people marching.
You've got protests.
All of a sudden, you had these
industry groups in Washington
with guys in suits and other
capitals for that matter.
It wasn't just an
American phenomenon.
And then you begin to
have those German marchers
and the Japanese marchers
and Vermont is recent,
but you had American marchers.
You began to get an anti-nuclear
movement with protests.
And after Three Mile Island,
the industry stopped.
Now this is the neat
part, which I actually
wasn't aware of until
I saw the article.
What did the industry try
to do to react to this?
Do you have the guys
in suits in Washington?
Are they a good reaction?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They tried to form
their own pro-nuclear movement.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They try
to do a pro-nuclear movement.
Did it work?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: How come?
AUDIENCE: Well, the article
mentions like the anti-nuclear
movement came from the people,
and they all felt like he--
or that an industry-backed
movement [INAUDIBLE]
so they were set
apart from the masses.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So they tried to do it,
but they really had trouble
making it authentic.
The anti-nuclear movement was
mom and pop and your uncle
and people really upset,
and the pro-nuclear movement
was industry people
with their ties off.
The phrase they use
in the businesses
to distinguish between
grassroots and AstroTurf.
Grassroots movements
are really genuine
and reflect popular sentiment.
AstroTurf is created, right?
You can see it when
you get emails--
when a congressional office gets
emails on an issue and they're
all identical.
You say, oh.
That's AstroTurf.
Somebody is really
pushing people to send--
somebody's saying to all their
employees, send this email.
That's not people
being passionate.
And it just didn't
work, didn't work.
It was an attempt
to create a movement
to affect energy policy.
Didn't work.
There's not a lot of social
movements in energy directly.
You see them more on
the environmental side.
And the piece by [? Rooked-- ?]
but environmental movements
affect energy, so it's
worth talking about.
That's a depressing article,
if you read the first part
in a bad mood.
Because he says the
environment's gotten worse
and species are getting
extinct, and we're
depleting natural resources.
I would just argue that he's
measuring against the past,
not against what
would have happened
but for the environmental
movement since the air
and the water in US and
Europe and many other places
has improved notably.
Nobody believes that, but
those are the numbers.
He argues-- so he's
trying to be quantitative.
He says that an
environmental movement can
work through lobbying, can
work through public opinion,
can work through
individual attitudes,
or through a Green Party,
as exist in some countries.
And the reason he does
this rather than thinking
about the ways we just finished
talking about, the more general
ways, is he's got measures
of all these things.
He's got measures of how
big the green movement is.
He's got measures
of public opinion.
He's got measures of
attitudes of various kinds,
and he certainly knows
whether there's a Green
Party that gets any votes.
So he can measure
these channels,
and he gives you
this nice picture.
So environmental movements
react to environmental problems.
I think interpreted
largely via sciences
is a little too
optimistic, but perceive
problems they can lobby.
They can be an interest group.
The Environmental Defense Fund,
the Natural Resources Defense
Council, the Friends of
the Earth, the Sierra Club.
There are more.
I'm trying to think of a few,
but they lobby as well as do
other things.
And so here are his channels.
So he has this very
interesting table.
Based on a set of
measures, he looks
at the strength of
environmental pressure groups.
He looks, based on
opinion polls, attitudes
toward the environment.
Is there a Green Party, and
how strong is the policy
and what's happened
to the environment?
It's interesting, the
US scores high in terms
of the environmental
pressure group.
We're kind of in the middle
in terms of attitudes.
We don't have a Green Party.
A lot of places don't
have green parties,
and we're kind of in the
middle on policy efforts, which
I think is, compared
to these countries,
I think is not far
off the mark roughly.
And we're in the middle in
terms of Environmental Quality.
I forget how he measures that.
That's a tough one because he's
got so many different things.
But this is the summary, his
summary of how these work.
And I must say--
so what he did was--
to be clear, the US
gets a three here.
It gets a two here.
It gets a one here.
It gets a one there.
And a one-- sorry, a two
there and a two there.
This is three.
This is two.
This is one.
And then he looks
at correlations,
which is not obviously
the right way to do it.
It's not, I would say,
the wrong way to do it.
But here they are.
OK.
So reading across, an
environmental pressure group
is most strongly associated
with the strength of policy
across countries.
Has very little to do with
whether there's a Green Party
or not, the stars or
statistical significance.
Very little to do with whether
there's a Green Party or not.
Why don't we have a Green
Party in the United States?
Brendan?
AUDIENCE: I thought we did.
Wasn't that Ralph
Nader [INAUDIBLE]??
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Oh.
Is that what he called it?
OK.
We might have once.
We don't have one now.
They do in Germany.
Various other countries do.
Well, Julian?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it's just insignificant.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's what?
AUDIENCE: It's
just insignificant.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Insignificant.
Yeah.
Well, maybe that's it.
Why don't we have one
that's significant?
AUDIENCE: Well, we've
always been heavily
polarized [INAUDIBLE]
Democrats or Republicans.
It's really hard for any
party to break into that
and make a three party
system, especially
a Green, which is like a
subset of the Democratic party.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It's very important.
Our electoral rules are
pretty important as they
are in some countries.
In some countries, you vote for
the party, not the candidate.
And the party has
representation in parliament,
depending on the percentage
of the votes it gets.
In that case, a Green Party
could get 5%, 6% of the votes
and have somebody in Washington.
Here, you've got to win a
majority to get into the house,
to get into the Senate.
It's very tough
for third parties
of any kind in our system.
Not in all systems.
I wouldn't say we're heavily--
we're heavily polarized now.
The Republican and Democratic
parties used to overlap more.
You used to actually have
conservative Democrats who
were more conservative
than liberal Republicans,
believe it or not.
So one of the reasons for
this is electoral laws.
But it's-- this is the
strongest correlation he's got.
And that's between
the importance
of environmental pressure groups
and the strength of policy
efforts to preserve
the environment, which
is sort of interesting.
He says the environmental
movement does matter.
He called-- the environmental
movement pressure.
If you think about it in
the US, we don't actually
have a lot of marches and
rallies for the environment.
We have interest
groups in Washington.
The Environmental Defense Fund,
the Sierra Club, the this,
the that.
So there are not a lot of
non-conventional actions being
done to save the environment.
There was a time in
the Pacific Northwest
when people would drive
iron spikes into trees
to prevent logging.
You don't hear much
of that anymore.
You don't hear people chaining
themselves to a nuclear power
plant much anymore.
So at this point,
we're lobbying.
Other places, stronger.
The other interesting
correlation
is how much stronger
the correlation
between environmental
movement pressure and policy
is than between
movement pressure
and his measure, at least, of
changes in the environment.
And part of that has to
do with where you are
and what the natural
conditions are, right?
Policy efforts in Los
Angeles are extraordinary.
Los Angeles has dirty air.
I don't think there's a European
country that takes as much pain
to preserve air quality as
there is done in the Los Angeles
basin.
It's just really hard.
It just doesn't ventilate.
So the notion that--
and if you're highly--
if it's a very
dense country, it's
kind of hard to preserve species
against development and so
on and so forth.
So, I don't know.
You believe the-- are you
persuaded by the article?
Comments on it?
Does that actually seem
like a plausible description
of interest group, of
environmental politics?
And I would notice also
that the difference--
the link between-- and, again,
causation is an inference.
Its correlation
is all we measure.
The link between individual--
between environmental
pressure and attitudes
isn't that great, which
makes sense in the US, right?
Because the Sierra Club isn't
trying to persuade you and me.
It's trying to persuade
Congress and the EPA.
So if it's successful
there, it wins.
Individual attitudes and
policy, not that strong either.
Not that strong a correlation.
So this is sort of a
picture of lobbying
where the environmental movement
acts directly on policy.
Doesn't act indirectly,
seems to me,
through parades, mass marches,
demonstrations, and any
of those other mechanisms.
I think that's a
fair description
of the movement now in the US.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Seems to me,
seems pretty reasonable
even though it's correlation
not causation, right?
Because although one
can make the argument
that interest groups [INAUDIBLE]
people would come out
after certain policy is made.
It seems to me that
the more logical flow
would be for information--
for those groups to be
formed initially and then
the policy is made.
So even though he
proved only correlation,
I think that that
flow makes more sense.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Oh, yeah.
No.
It's not-- is not from--
in fact, it can
go the other way.
Because when Reagan
basically declared war
on environmental policy, the
memberships of those groups
soared because
they saw a threat.
And the groups sent out
mass mailings, saying, look
what this guy is trying
to do to the environment,
and the money flowed in.
So the question of, are
they exerting pressure?
Yes, but in that case, they
were exerting more pressure
in a much more hostile
environment politically.
So yeah.
I think that the direction
is generally right.
Any other comments?
Yeah, Charlotte?
AUDIENCE: I guess--
I know he had a system
for doing all this,
but it seems like you could
come up with a different system
and get different results.
And--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You're
just not a natural sociologist.
You're just--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
apply to this.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, well--
but this raises a general
problem in social science.
In economics, we get
lucky because you
have dollars and quantities
and tons and stuff.
This is sociology.
What have you got?
You've got attitudes.
You've got some
ill-defined measures
of this, that, and the other.
You want to say, are
environmental groups effective?
It seems to me you're stuck
doing something like this.
You could do it well or poorly.
I think this is pretty good.
I'm still not-- I hadn't
thought about it much,
but it just didn't
strike me that just
running ordinary correlations
is quite the right way to do it.
But there's no obviously
better way that comes to mind.
I don't know.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: I think I'd be more
persuaded by case studies where
it did work in the case
where there was a Green Party
or wasn't a Green
Party, or didn't
work in that sort of case.
I think I'd be able to
relate to that more.
And I know that's not
as general as what
he's trying to do here--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --but I think that
maybe he makes it too general.
Like, what's the
difference between a 0.6
and a 0.7 on his little scale?
That doesn't mean
anything to me.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No,
I'm sort of with you.
I'd prefer to understand one
or two cases well than 18 cases
badly.
The issue he's-- well, it's
a general problem, right?
You do a case study.
You have a study where
n equals 1, right?
You can't test the
hypothesis with n equals 1.
So if you're interested in
testing a hypothesis, say,
environmental movements
operate mainly
through individual attitudes,
you can't do n equals 1.
You could probably do before
and after in a case study.
You could try it.
But, of course, you can't
hold everything else constant.
No, I'm sympathetic.
I'm not excited about
uni-dimensional measures
of policy efforts, right?
I mean, US policy is
stronger than some
of those other countries
on some dimensions
and weaker on others.
European tax systems
favor use of diesels.
Diesels produce
small particulates.
Small particulates have
terrible health effects.
So are they more
environmentally conscious
than we are because
they recycle or more,
or are we more
environmentally conscious
because we avoid diesels?
Very hard to do.
Yeah.
No, I take the point.
Anybody else?
OK.
We will, Wednesday, talk
about US environmental policy,
walking through the case
study and looking beyond it.
So please read that.
And for those of
you who came late,
Monday we will
see if we can find
a guest speaker for
an hour, and we'll
do an hour's soft shoe on--
a half an hour soft shoe
on green growth, reflecting
the will of a narrow majority.